here for a reaction the president of the
national border patrol Council Brandon
Judd and Arizona attorney general Mark
bronovich gentlemen thank you I I don't
even know I can't even count the number
of times I've seen you both on Fox News
talking about the Border onesie attorney
general one's in the border patrol you
live it you breathe it secretary Marcus
continues to testify to Congress that
the border is secure Brandon Judd is it
secure
absolutely not let me give you evidence
notice that secretary Marcus will never
actually give evidence he won't give you
facts I'm going to give you some facts
we've had more than a million people
cross our border illegally and have been
able to evade apprehensions since
President Biden has been in office
that's not a secure border we have had
more fentanyl across our borders and
make it into our streets and kill our
children and U.S citizens than ever in
the history of the United States that's
not a secure border the cartels are
generating a record profit that is not a
secure border every single thing that
we're seeing on our border clearly
points to that there is absolute chaos
that there is a crisis but if this
Administration is not willing to Define
what is currently going on they're never
going to try to look for solutions that
is the problem that we face this is
absolute bad governance that we're
seeing by this Administration
uh Mr attorney general the the Secretary
of Homeland Security
despite all those numbers that Brandon
just brought up says the border is
secure what's your reaction and
perspective from the state of Arizona
well Jason everyone is entitled to their
own opinion but not their own facts as
Brandon just laid out
um these are mind-numbing numbers we
know the cartels have seized operational
control of not only our Southern border
but I think with sometimes what's more
dangerous is this Progressive left that
sees control of the Biden White House
that's literally lying to Americans and
people are dying as a result and so I
just to put in perspective since Joe
Biden became president enough people
have illegally crossed our Southern
border to fill the a state like Alabama
or even Louisiana enough fentanyl every
year now is crossing our border being
seized to kill every single person in
the United States and that's why we're
seeing a record amount of people dying
more than 100 000 people last year alone
in the United States so border security
is National Security and brand didn't
even mention people on the terror watch
list being apprehended so America is
less safe our cities are more dangerous
as a result of the failures of secretary
mayorkas and Joe Biden and it's taken
way too long for Congress to finally do
something and I'm hoping now that the
public Republicans control Congress they
will make sure that secretary mayargas
and Joe binder held to account and if
that means impeaching him so be it
yeah impeachment may be the very answer
the only answer that's left at the table
here you know you look at that that
thermal imaging uh video that fox shot
how is that not an invasion of our
Southern board that that's not a secure
border that is an invasion that I'm
looking at right there from my
perspective but Brandon uh the secondary
is trying to blame this on migration
throughout the entire Western Hemisphere
I can't name a single country other than
the United States that these people are
trying to flock to
of course he's going to say that he's
going to deflect from his failures he
has done such a poor job in in his in
his office that we're currently seeing
this you know you talk about Invasion
and I am grateful to attorney general
brnovich because he's talked about the
invasion before this is organized this
is um by cartels these are criminal
organizations that are very organized
and and they're sending all these people
they're sending the fentanyl that is in
fact an invasion and I believe that what
Texas just just did by declaring an
invasion I think that it was the right
move even though it's going to get
challenged I believe that the Supreme
Court will in fact
um hold up their determination that an
invasion has taken place because it is
being driven by organized crime
Mr attorney general we have a short
amount of time is it an invasion
Yeah we actually issued a formal legal
opinion the first in our country's
history saying that what is going on on
our Southern border does constitute an
constitute Invasion people go to
azag.gov to read that opinion it's very
well researched and I do agree with
Brandon that the Supreme Court should
uphold this because the federal
government is supposed to be doing this
and if they're failing to do their job
the states have the right to defend
themselves and that's what governor
Abbott's trying to do
uh Brandon Judd attorney general
bronovich thank you so much for laying
out the perspective unfortunately I
believe we'll have you on again to talk
about the same problem but it is out
there and everybody needs to be educated
on it thank you again for joining us on
Hannity hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else